- Hey guys, welcome back
to the Kelly Clarkson Show.
(audience applauding)
I'm obviously not Kelly Clarkson.
I'm Simu Liu, and I am guest
hosting for Kelly today.
(audience applauding)
We have a small, but very,
very vocal audience of crew,
and I've got Kumail Nanjiani with me.
(audience applauding)
Let's let's take a look
at a clip of Kumail
kicking ass in Eternals.
(intense electronic music)
(kicks and punches cracking)
(body thumping)
(men grunting)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- What are you clapping for?
(audience laughing)
What was that?
- So weird.
- Yeah, but there must have
been some sort of mistake.
- I have no idea
what happened there.
- It's so surprising
that the most badass clip from your movie
just happened to play.
- You know, I was playing
around on Windows Movie Maker
last night.
(Kumail laughing)
I just kind of, you know.
- A Simu edit, of Shang-Chi?
- Yeah, it must have gotten
slipped in somewhere.
Okay, for real, for real.
Here is a clip of Kumail kicking ass.
(intense orchestral music)
(Makkari whooshing)
(hand projectiles whirring)
(hand projectiles zapping)
(monster roaring)
(Makkari impacting)
(hand projectiles whirring)
(hand projectile blasting)
(monster roaring)
(rocks crumbling)
(audience applauding)
(Simu clapping)
- Honestly,
you should have played one
more clip from your movie.
(Simu laughing)
That would've been really funny.
It would've.
- One more.
I just, I don't have it
in me to be that cruel.
It's my first time hosting.
(audience laughing)
But you know, there's all always time.
All right, all right.
No more fooling around.
We're gonna get to the
meat of the interview.
You ready for the hard-hitting questions?
- Oh, here we go.
- Here we go.
Your wife, she had an idea for a website
that could break stereotypes.
Can you explain
what that was?
- Yeah.
So she had this,
'cause you know, I'm Muslim.
My whole family's Muslim,
and he gets to see a side of
Muslims that people don't.
And so she wanted to have a website
called Muslims Having Fun.
(Simu and audience laughing)
Which is just like pictures
of Muslims eating ice cream.
On the rollercoaster.
You go to any theme park.
There's always Muslims there
having a blast.
- Disneyland.
- Yeah, Disney.
Having,
we should specify.
- We should specify.
We do, you know.
- Disneyland, the best
of all the theme parks.
Yeah, so she just wanted to have a website
called Muslims Having Fun,
and it's just like Muslims playing tennis
and stuff like that.
(audience laughing)
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's a great idea.
I think it would do well.
Make a killing off the site.
- I think so, I think so.
Have you had a lot of...
Since your movie came out,
you must have heard from a lot of people.
I'm asking you a question now.
- You are, yes.
I'm feeling that's the--
- In terms of representation,
how does it feel to you
when people say that they see
themselves reflected on screen
as a superhero, because of you?
- You are asking me the
question that I have,
and you probably got asked,
700 times during the press tour.
- That's right.
- So you know this question.
- [Kumail] Yes.
- You probably asked me 'cause
you knew I was gonna ask you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Simu] And then you preempt me
by asking me to make me.
- That's my superpower.
- Oh, okay.
- Reflection.
(audience laughing)
- Wow.
- I don't wanna
answer it again.
- I thought it was just
finger guns.
- Why don't you answer it again?
I answered it more recently.
Your movie came out few
months ago. (Simu laughing)
- It is an incredible feeling.
I mean, I've said it like 4,000 times,
but it does like every community
deserves to to see themselves in that way.
And, you know, I'm sure
you can appreciate too
when you're growing up and
watching Hollywood movies
like Jurassic Park and
Indiana Jones, Star Wars.
It just, you know?
- Yeah, I mean, I was always
the bad guy in those movies.
- Yeah.
- It's like, "Oh, someone
who looks like me,
he's got a scheme."
- Not having fun.
- Yeah, he's not having fun.
(audience laughing)
And he wants to make sure nobody has fun.
So it's fun to see.
I mean, I've seen so many movies
where the bad guys
are literally speaking
my language, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're like scheming
and planning
and there's no subtitles because
who cares what they think.
(audience laughing)
That's true.
You can catch that in movies
in the 90s growing up,
I would notice that.
So it's awesome to finally have people
who look like me, who aren't bad guy.
I had my niece who like,
loves this movie.
She's five years old.
She's adorable.
She's so excited.
I think I have, I think
we have a clip of her.
This is her learning to dance.
Watching the Bollywood scene.
She's...
- [Simu] Oh my God.
(audience applauding)
This is her excited seeing me.
- [Simu] Oh my God.
(audience clapping)
(Simu and Kumail laughing)
(audience applauding)
- That's Liana.
- She's like him!
Him specifically.
- That's the one I like!
Leanna.
- I love it, I love it.
I love sharing cultures.
One way, obviously, to get
to know different cultures
is food.
So I want to know what's
a food that you love
that you think that everyone should try.
We talked about maybe like a dessert.
- Well, there's.
Oh, you're talking about pandan cake.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Did you, I mean.
So pandan cake is, how
would you describe it?
It's a plant.
- I want you to describe it.
It's your interview.
- It's a very.
(audience laughing)
(Simu laughing)
I could turn the tables
again. (Simu laughing)
It's a plant.
It's a very specific green color
to make cakes and stuff out of it.
And it sort of tastes like,
it's a little bit bitter,
but it's a little bit vanilla tasting too.
It's a very specific taste.
And a lot of far East-Asian countries
have dessert made from it.
And it was my favorite
dessert flavor growing up.
And it's very hard to find here.
Did you--
- Are you on dessert right now?
If I materialized one
right in front of you,
hypothetically, you would eat some?
- Don't say stuff you can't.
- Justin, let's just
bring it out and let's just see.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God.
(Kumail laughing)
- Thank you so much, Justin.
That's wonderful.
Here you go.
- That is amazing!
You got pandan cake.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
It's just,
this is from one of your
favorite bakeries, I believe.
Mina, right?
- Oh really?
- Mina Rocks, LA.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, let's--
- You made it, that's amazing.
Let's try it right now.
- Yeah.
Oh my God.
(audience applauding)
- Can I just.
- I love watching you eat carbs.
- It's so good.
(audience laughing)
- You know, it just makes me happy.
- Oh my God.
- And it makes me feel a
little bit better about myself.
- Mmm.
- So there's gotta be,
this is only two slices.
(audience laughing)
There's gotta be rest of the
cake here somewhere, right?
- I'm not joking.
- I think we can.
(audience laughing)
I think we can arrange that.
- There's gotta be,
wait, why are you putting it down?
- Well, 'cause it's a little
dry without some liquid
and it was a perfect segue to my thing.
- Yes.
- [Simu] 'Cause you know
what I like is boba.
- Yes, you love boba.
- And I think
we have some of that too.
(audience applauding)
Out there, Justin, could you?
Perfect.
- Thank you.
- [Justin] Very welcome.
- Thank you so much.
Some boba from Boba Guys.
- Mmm.
- So now we're having some pandan cake
with some boba.
- Oh my God, I'm so happy right now.
(audience laughing)
This is great.
Oh, I did not think this is gonna happen.
- I was afraid that you were gonna tell me
that you couldn't eat any of it.
- Well no.
- I'm so glad that--
- I can do whatever I want.
(audience laughing)
Movie's out.
I don't give a...
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- All right, you keep eating.
I'll just talk.
So we're both superheroes.
I think we both grew up loving
the culture and the comics.
Do you want to play a game
to test our knowledge?
(audience applauding)
We have to, basically,
I have to get you to take a
shot of hot sauce or something.
- Sure, I'll do it.
- This is one of the ways.
Unless you can beat me in a game
of superhero knowledge
- I don't think I can,
but I want to try.
- I don't think you can
either, but you know.
- Let's do it.
- [Simu] Let's try it.